はい まあ芸能人についてまたいます
芸能人のターラプッタが釈尊に問います
パーリ語はもう一応取り出せないんです
私の師匠たちはこのように教えています
もし芸能人が舞台の上で
または集いの前で 事実も嘘もかき混ぜて人を喜ばせる
笑わせるならば その芸能人は死後
パハサ正気ですね という展開に生まれます
この教えについて釈尊の意見は何でしょうかと
芸能人がね なんか落ち込んでいる人々をもう喜ばせるでしょ
楽しませるでしょ 一生懸命頑張ってね
だったら天国ぐらい行かないとね
なんか日本はそう思ってるみたいんですけど
日本ではもう芸能人の話なら信じるというね
まあ結構頭のいい芸能人もいることはいますけどね
もう何人かはね 他はもうほとんど学校に行ってないんです
昨日テレビ見て あの爆笑問題でしたっけ？昇太さん
なんか番組やってて まあくだらん笑い番組です
やっぱりまあすごいしっかりして頭がいい人間だなと
とわかりますけど 何か役に立つ笑いといえば
まあその人ぐらいですね
笑いは笑いですけど 中は何かすごい鋭いことを言うんです
釈尊がノーコメントという立場を取るが
3回目も聞かれますからね
でお釈迦様の答え 尊重
まあこのターラ 人々は欲に束縛されている
彼らが劇場やその他の集いに行って
欲を興奮させるものをなおさら喜びのために観察する
お釈迦様はすごく分析するんです
人間っていうのは欲に束縛されていますよ
それで舞台ね 何て言いますか
そういう劇場になんで行くのかというと
自分持っている欲をなおさら興奮させたいんです
人々は怒りに束縛されている
怒り持ってますね それで劇場に行って
その自分持っている怒りをね
なおさら興奮させたいんですね
無知に束縛されている
それで無知を興奮したいんですね
この感情 興奮するとみんな喜びだと思っているんです
劇場ドラマを見て泣いちゃったりして
ああ 楽しかった どうやって
それがわかりませんだけどね
で やっぱり人間っていうのは楽しかったり
怒ったり もう例えばこの怒りでしょ
この映画なんかはね もう大量殺人の映画ばっかりでしょ
だからそれが自分持ってる怒りを興奮させるんですね
それになりに世の中には素晴らしい結果もありますからね
子供は親を殺すとかね
誰か殺してみたがるんです
映画で見たんだから 漫画で見るんだから
そこで村長自分も放逸に陥っていて
芸能人は芸能人は他人を徹底的に放逸に陥れる
だから芸能人も放逸なんですよ
まあくだらんことばっかり考えて
修行なんかはしません
ネタばっかり考えているんです
新しい振り付けを考えているんです
それを訓練しているんです
失敗なく 舞台でどうやってこれはもう表現できるのかと
舞台ではもうもしかすると 1分
2分かもしれませんよ
出るのは しかし そのためにもうもう何日でも何日でも訓練する
だから全部放逸なんですね
そこで舞台に上がって
腕を振って人々を笑わせる
楽しませる それで 彼らがその行為によって死後パハサという地獄に落ちます
ということになるんです
地獄に落ちますよと 人を放逸に陥れたんだよということで
村長 芸をもって人を笑わせることで天国に行けそうと思うなら
それは邪見であります
人を笑わせたんだからで
天国には行けません そう思っているならば邪見ですと
邪見を持つ人に死後の道は 2つです
地獄か畜生ですと ターラプッタが泣き崩れる
この話を聞いたら 自分の芸の伝承でスーッと天国に行けるんだから
天国に行けるんだからとかね
そう言われると その芸能人たちが修行しようとか
宗教真理聞こうという気持ちにもなりません
俺たちは俺たちなりにまあ宗教家だよと思ってるんだから
自分たちが芸能人だからもう人間に人間を導く権利があるんだよと
だから衆議院選挙とかなんとかで出すんです
何の役にも立たない馬鹿どもたちを
それでターラブタがいきなりお釈迦様の言葉を聞いてもう泣き崩れちゃったんです
それでお釈迦様はあんた言ったでしょ？質問するなよと
お釈迦質問されたら本当のこと言わなくちゃあかんだから
慰めると このターラブタが
いえ 違いますよとお釈迦様
私はお釈迦様に言われたことに泣いているんじゃないんだよと
お釈迦様は本当のことを言ったことを本心に信じています
お釈迦様の言われたことに泣いてはいませんと
私は泣いているのは あの連中に騙されたことであると
自分の父親とか もう師匠たちに
あの連中に長き渡って我々は騙されて
地獄に行く道をね 天国に行くんだよと言われてきたんだから
それに腹が立って泣いてるんだから
まあ真面目な人ですよ
しかし 彼が泣いたのは
釈尊の言葉に対してではなく
今まで師匠たちに騙されて悪の道を歩ませたことに対してですということで
そういうことで 芸能人も格好は良くない
仏教から見ればもう逆かわいそうということですね
はい それから神々の話に行きます
この神々の話の場合は
よく出てくるのは神々の王様なんですね
まあ天界は仏教では６あります
それで この人間との何らかの関わりを持っている天界は２つありまして
この上はそんなもう興味もない
人間の世界に その２階の
神々の中で王様一人がいるんです
神々の王であるサッカ
帝釈天ですね が考える格好良い人
サップリセとは ではまあそこら辺にいる一般人に聞かないで
では神々の王様に聞いてみたらどうですかね
かっこいい人って誰ですか？と
この人はものすごい真剣な敬虔な仏教徒なお釈迦様のもうすっごくいい弟子なんです
弟子というか もうお釈迦様の家来みたいに
いつでもまあお釈迦様のそばにいたり
もういろいろお世話したり
もうよくよく面倒見た人なんです
まあ神でいながら マーターペッティバランジャントゥン
クレージェッダペチャイナンサンナンサキラサンバサンペーすね
ヤッパハイナンマッシェーラヴィナジェユッタンスッチャンコーダビブンナランタンウェーデーヴァーターヴァティンサアースサップリソイティ
というまあ この神の言葉なんです
では意味はね じゃあ意味は何でしょうか
1 両親を養う  2 目上の人々を尊重する
3 優しい言葉遣い  4 噂はでしたっけ？はしない
5 欲張らない 皆と分かち合う
布施ですね  6 真実を語る
いわゆる嘘は言わない
7 怒りに打ち勝つ 怒らない
この人は善人であると
33点の神々が言うと
これ善人というのはサップリサという単語で
かっこいい人っていう意味なんです
神々に聞くと いわゆる神様の神々の王様に聞くと
この 7つ揃ってる人がかっこいいんです
残念なことに 現代社会ではこれ一つもないんでかっこ悪いんですよ
親の面倒を見るならばすごいかっこ悪い
世間の考えはね 目上の人を尊重するならばすごいかっこ悪い
すごい自分 私こそ偉いぞということをしないと
だから本当の世界は逆なんです
人間がかっこいいと思うのは
もうとんでもないかっこ悪い臭い生き方なんですよ
親の面倒見ること 親戚の中で目上の人々にも尊重すること
怒らないこと 嘘は言わないこと
それからわがままではなくて
自分が持っているものはみんなと分かち合って
じゃあみんな仲良くしましょうかと
それがかっこいいんだろうと
だからかっこいい人は死後天国に行こうとしたっても
向こうは断りますからね
私は人間の世界でも大人気者で
みんなかっこいいやとヨン様と言われていたんだよと
と言ってもね それでは決めません
正確なんですよ  これが神から見たかっこいい人の条件なんです
だから神に好かれたければ
これ守ることなんですよ
この 7つのこと 帝釈天がこの 7つにすごく凝ってます
だから本当に守る場合は本人が心配しますよ
すごい忙しいんですけど
もし我々はものすごく真剣に親を親
親を養ったり 目上に敬ったりすると
結構気になるんです 向こうは
だからいろいろ面倒見てあげたり
助けてくれたりはする
死後はもうとにかく招待状が来ます
結構 お釈迦様の時代で
この在家の方々が亡くなると
みんなボケません だから仏教徒だからね
すごい意識がしっかりして亡くなるんで
その時は一応いろんな神々が来るんです
来て話し合ったり うちのところに来てくださいとかね
別のいえ うちの方がもっといいんだよとかね
このチッタという この間教えた会でも勉強した経典あります
このチッタさんも在家の人
亡くなる時はもう神々があっちこっちから来ていろんなことを言うんですね
その人のことを好きで好きでたまらんですよ
肉体はもうもう壊れてもう死にかけてますけど
やっぱり心は美しいんだからね
神様は心に惹かれるんです
ただ チッタさんが神々にね
一言葉を言うんです うるさいのは死ぬ瞬間でもうるさかったんですけど
チッタさんは で ちょこちょこと帝釈天の話は続きます
帝釈天が尊敬する人 そこで神の王が尊敬する人々はいるんです
人間を ゲーガハッタープンヤカラーシーラワントウパーサカダンメーナダーラポーセンティヘーナマッサーミマハターリ
帝釈天は出かけるとき
四方八方に これ間違ってます
礼をするんです この礼じゃないんです
でさ マハターリが 人間皆あなたを拝む
あなたは誰を拝んでるんでしょうかねと問うんです
帝釈って神の王様でしょ
四方八方に礼をする この一緒に行くマータリー神がわからないんですね
人間の世界でね みんなこの神様を拝んでいるんです
こういうあなた誰を拝んでいるんですか？と言ったら
これ答えるんですよ 善行為をする
道徳を守る 正法で家族を養う
才気の人々を拝んでいると答えるんです
ということは 神々が人間を拝んでいるんです
といっても神々の王様なんですね
他 そんな性格は良くないんだから
神々はね 拝んでないと思いますけど
王様はすごい性格はいいんです
しかし どんなくだらん人を拝むわけじゃないんです
イエーガハッタープンヤから善行為をする人々
毎日何か良いことをする
そういう人々はすごく立派だな
かっこいいんだなと 羨ましいと神様が思うんです
それからシーラワンと道徳的
すごい道徳を守っている
だから神様が羨しがるんですね
なんとすごい人でしょうかと
ダンメガラーポーセンティ
家族を持ってますからね
家族を正しく仕事をして
不良不正なことをしないで家族を養っている
彼らに礼をしていますよと
これは神の話を抜かして考えても
いかに人間が正しく いわゆるいかにではないんですね
人間の評価するべきポイントは何なのかと
もう大胆に言っているところなんです
体形じゃないんです 芸能人か何かじゃないんで
歌えるかないかじゃないんです
道徳を守っているのかと
悪いことをして食べているのかと
それなんです 悪いことを何もしないで
正しく仕事をして 収入で家族を養っているのかと
良いことをしているのかと
それが神に勝るという言葉でしょ
なんか人間での神に勝る生き方でのすごく嫌がるんですね
神々の王が拝む人々を私も拝むと行者が言う
これまあ対話 歌の対話ですからね
で この歌を歌ったんだから
帝釈天が次にこのマーターリさんの我々の神様が
王様が拝む人々のこと
私もでは拝ませていただきますと
そういう人間に礼をしたんだと
今はないでしょうね 今
神々が拝みたくてももう空き家だと
世界は で 神々の差別意識
帝釈天はサンガに礼をしていたんです
まあまた他の出来事エピソードで
あのある森のところでお坊さんたちが修行していて
もうもうすごい僧のお坊さんたちで
もうかっこ悪いんですよ
見た目はボロボロ服着て
もうもう本当にもうボロボロで
しかし帝釈天が一生懸命礼をするんです
それを見てまたマーターリがね
語るんです 腐る肉体を持っている
肉体は神々にすごい気持ち悪いんだそうです
人間の肉体は腐ってるんだからね
腐ってるものの中で生活している
それで人間生活 あのお坊さんたちはすごくもう人間行かない汚いところで住んでいたんです
森の中で 別にすごい立派な公園でも立派なお寺でもなかったんです
まあただ森の中に入って
それもゴミのゴミもいっぱいあるところで
そこで生活して修行している
だから肉体も汚いんだと
ホームレスですからね
結局は 臭いんだと その上住んでいるところはものすごく汚いんだよ
いつでも喉が渇き お腹が空いている
それは病気のことがあの汚い臭い体
肉体ですけど いつでもそれが病気で
喉が渇いたとか お腹が空いたとか
なんだこの体はと 神々の体だからもう比較になりません
神々の体はすごい 血液とか何もないんだからね
細胞も何もないんです
だからとっても綺麗というか
清らかなんです こんなパクパク食べたりはないんです
体壊れる 年取ることもないんです
業が終わったらさっと消えるだけ
年取らない だから神々から見れば
人間っていうのはもうもう何十も近寄りたくないぐらい臭いんだそうです
また 家さえも持ってないこの人々をなぜあなたは好むんですか？と
まあ普通の人だったらね
もうたとえかっこ悪くても家ぐらい持ってますけどね
このサンガの比丘たちは家さえない
木の下に住んでる あんた
なんであの汚い連中を好きですか？と聞くんですね
いうマーターリよ では出家善人のことをなぜ好むのかと
帝釈天が語る まあ一応ちょっと文章間違ってますけど
まあ語ってあげましょうということで
マーターリ 君に教えてあげる
なんで我々は私はあの善人のことを好きですか？と
彼らは何も持たないんです
私のもの 私のものって何もないんだと
何ですか これは 蔵がないんだと
出家だから 何もない いただいたもので体を維持する
体を維持するためにも料理を作ったり
いろいろものを取ったり
生命を殺したりはしません
人間が残したものが はい
どうぞ使ってくださいと言っちゃうと
それでいわゆる微塵でも世間に負担はかけない
ご飯のためにもということです
生活しているんだと 清らかな思考をする
それだけではなくて この思考がとっても清らかですよ
する賢者である 沈黙を守り
自己制御している 神々はアスラたちと戦うが
彼らは相手が敵であっても戦わない
我々神々がアスラたちと腹が立って喧嘩しますよと
しかし 神々さえも戦いますけどね
このブッダの弟子たちは
相手が敵であっても戦わないんだよと
怒りが世界で 怒りの世界で怒りなく
執着がある 怒りがある世界かなね
執着がある世界で執着がなく
安穏に達している彼らを私は礼をして拝むと
だからそこでやっぱりわかりますね
どちらの方がかっこいいかと
心の清らかということがかっこいいということなんです
帝釈天がものすごく好きで
もうなんで差別意識と書いたのかというと
やっぱり神々が本当に人間のことはものすごく嫌悪で嫌だという感じで見ているんです
もう全然近寄りたくはない
だから神がみんなに霊験とかね
よく挟まないんです それまた誰しもが人間狙って言葉を言うというのはありえないんです
マーテリ神が言う 神々の王サッカが拝む人々であるならば
彼らは確かにこの世で偉大なる存在であるに違いありません
神々の王が拝む人々を私も拝みますと
かっこよい生き方とは
神々も羨ましく思う生き方なんです
俗世間の無知な人に認められても面白くありませんと
だからこの人気者の人っていうのは
一番もう若者 子供たちに認められるだけでしょ
これで面白くないんです
今若者の間ですごい人気ありますよと
くだらないに決まってます
それだったらそういう世界ではなくて
やっぱり神々さえも羨ましいと思われる人間になることなんです
だから そこまですごく難しく感じるかもしれませんだけど
すごいシンプルですよ
ごく普通に道徳を守って
法律を破らないで 嘘を言わないで
怒りに負けないでしっかり生活すれば
それで十分だという話なんです
題目を 1万回唱えなく唱えなくてもいいんです
それで商売繁盛できるそうとかね
はい まあそこら辺でちょっと一旦休憩することにしましょうか
はい では始まります はい
それからまあ最高を目指すというね
人間なら最高を目指さなきゃいけないんですね
では最高を目指すってどういうことかと
キンスーデヴィッタンプリサスセッタン
キンススチンのスクマワハティ
人にとって優れた宝物とは何？まあ
最高だから 一番最高な宝物って何でしょうか？と
人は何を集めれば幸福になるのでしょうか？と
で これ最高なことを聞いているので
お釈迦様に聞いているので
まあ聞いたのは本当は人間ではなかったんですけど
あの で もう宝物 何があったら一番最高だと言えるのかっていうことですね
何を集めればよろしいでしょうかと
サッディーデヴィッタンプリサスセッタン
ダンモーシュチンのスクマワハティ
信 信仰の信ですね 真理に対する確信という意味なんです
あれ 嘘を信じるんじゃなくて
事実を発見して この事実を
信じるんです まあ事実を信じなくていいんですけど
事実ですから やっぱり納得いかないとね
優れた宝物ですと まあ例えば今日の話でも
初めからの人間が論理的に因果法則にのっとってどう生きるべきかという話ですから
それはそのまま事実だと思いますよ
それでやっぱりそれが本当の道であると
その方向で生きていなくちゃいけないんだという確信なんですね
信というのは まあそんなこと言われたってもね
私たちは昔からもう神におねだりしてきたんだから
これからもやるぞと思っちゃうと
もう話したっても意味がないということになっちゃうんですね
で 役に立ってないんですね
だから信 物事を納得できる
確信できる能力が最高の宝物なんです
それから法を習うことによって幸福になる
法っていうのはまた正しい生き方
ブッダの教えでもあります
それを学ぶ だからこの力学というんですか
まあそういう地理学やらあれこれと学んだんだからといってね
たくさんの本を集めたんだからで
そんな通ったことはないんですよ
本当に生命って何なのかという
ブッダに教えたものを学んで学んで学んで
頭をいっぱいしておけば
もう最高の集まり それは最高な修習なんですよ
キンスハヴェ ちょっとずれてます
キンスハヴェーサードゥタランラサーナ
カタンジービンジービテマーフセッタ
人にとって最高の美味とは何？どのような生き方が最高だと言えるのでしょうか？と
まあこのラサっていうのは美味しいということでもありますけど
まあ別の意味もありますしね
サッチャンハヴェーサードゥタランラサーナ
パンニャージービンジービテマーフセッタ
最高の美味は真理です
知恵に基づいた生き方が最高だというんです
だから最高にかっこいい人間っていうのは
知恵に基づいた生き方をする人なんです
知恵がある 理性がある
それだったら他何もなくてもすごいんです
だから簡単ですよ 最高にかっこいい人間になることは
理性を育てる 理性的に生きてみる
誰にも負けません その人は